donald trump era consciente de que
algunos de sus partidarios estaban
armados cuando los llamo a marchar en el
capitolio el 6 de enero de 2021 eso es
según una ex ayudante de la casa blanca
reveló a un comité de la cámara de
representantes- una conversación que el
ex presidente supuestamente tuvo con su
jefe de personal cuatro días antes del
evento
hoy el presidente decir algo así no me
importa que tengan armas no están aquí
para hacerme daño dejen entrar a mis
partidarios
la joven que trabajaba junto al despacho
oval describe una atención creciente en
los días previos al mitin del ex
presidente confiesa que al parecer el
jefe del gabinete de donald trump y le
advirtió de que podía ocurrir algo más
grave finalmente el 6 de enero cientos
de partidarios del ex presidente entran
a la fuerza en el capitolio para
impugnar la elección de joe biden una
marea humana a la que supuestamente
intentó unirse el propio trump
el presidente dijo algo así como soy el
maldito presidente llévame al capitolio
ahora mismo el presidente se adelantó el
vehículo para agarrar el volante el
guardia de seguridad lo agarró del brazo
y le dijo señor tiene que quitar la mano
del volante trump utilizó entonces su
mano libre para lanzarse contra el
guardia
el republicano no tardó en rebatir este
testimonio en su red social
calificándolo de retorcido y falso al
igual que el trabajo de la comisión en
su conjunto durante casi un año la
comisión ha recogido más de mil
testimonios en un intento de arrojar luz
sobre la actuación del ex mandatario
antes durante y después del asalto al
capitolio